yo ya ha completado el recuento manuel
de sus 5 millones de votos y yo baiden
sigue siendo el ganador en la reñida
carrera el demócrata tiene 12 mil 284
votos más que donald trump este
desarrollo reduce las posibilidades del
presidente de anular el resultado de las
elecciones pero trump y sus partidarios
han dicho que el recuento en georgia no
tiene sentido porque muchos de los votos
son fraudulentos y no es lo único
había un plan desde un lugar
centralizado para ejecutarse estos
diversos actos de fraude electoral
centrado específicamente en las grandes
ciudades y centrado específicamente como
se puede imaginar en las grandes
ciudades controladas por los demócratas
la compañía que cuenta nuestro voto es
propiedad de dos venezolanos que fueron
aliados de chacras
giuliani que ha perdido múltiples
intentos legales para revertir los
resultados en los estados clave está
planeando lanzar nuevas medidas mientras
tanto los demócratas están cada vez más
preocupados para la transición de poder
y creo que están siendo testigos de una
increíble irresponsabilidad se está
enviando un mensaje increíblemente
dañino al resto del mundo sobre cómo
funciona la democracia y creo que es
bueno no sé su motivo pero creo que es
totalmente irresponsable según the
washington post la campaña de trump
quiere ahora bloquear la certificación
de los resultados en tres estados entre
los cuales está pensilvania michigan en
caso de bloqueo los republicanos que
están a cargo en estos estados podrían
mandar representantes de su partido al
colegio electoral el 14 de diciembre una
hipótesis poco probable para los
observadores